[Música]
cuando hablamos de violencia doméstica
que es lo primero que se nos viene a la
mente
y quiero que hoy visualicen a una joven
de 29 años
graduada en el exterior de buena familia
que usa su tiempo para arreglarse verse
bien
madre de tres hijos
siempre pendiente de todas las
actividades extracurriculares
la primera voluntaria de su tiempo y su
creatividad para proyectos y fiestas y
demás cosas que alguna institución o una
escuela se le pueda ocurrir para hacer
la educación de un niño más divertida
una mujer extremadamente social
extrovertida de muchos amigos de esas
mujeres que le hablan hasta una piedra
a muchos eventos sociales donde siempre
se ve que la fotografía para las
revistas para los periódicos y siempre
se le ve con una sonrisa de oreja a
oreja
sin embargo ya cuando llega a su casa es
una mujer extremadamente triste tomando
hasta nueve pastillas antidepresivas
diarias con el pensamiento frecuente de
qué pasaría si me toma este frasco de
pastillas
estaría tan mal se acabó con mi vida
me extrañaría
ya en su casa no contesta el teléfono
no le dedica tiempo a sus hijos y
francamente solo se la pasa en la cama
durmiendo
ahora quiero que se imaginen una noche
entre las 10 y 11 pm cuando todo en la
casa está tranquilo
los niños están en su cama durmiendo las
luces apagadas
todas excepto una
la del closet principal
y la puerta cerrada con llave
y esta joven
y gritando desde lo más profundo de sus
pulmones hacia unas de lucia que se
encontraban milagrosamente abiertas de
esa noche
auxilio alguien llame a la policía
el día siguiente la remiten a medicina
forense
porque está con un fuerte dolor de
cabeza que le baja hasta la mandíbula
así que le deciden hacer un examen de
resonancia magnética
ya dentro de esa máquina con el olor a
muerto que la rodeaba porque justo al
lado se encontraba la morgue
con solo una pared que la separaba de
entre los vivos y los muertos
contemplaba a ella lo que le había
sucedido tan sólo unas horas anteriores
y con convicción se dijo ya no voy a
aguantar más agresiones físicas ni
verbales
y voy a salir de esto
ahora como reconocemos a una víctima de
violencia doméstica
tendremos que creer que una víctima de
violencia doméstica es una persona que
vive en un estrato socioeconómico bajo
que vive en las áreas rurales o que se
demuestra ante el mundo como una persona
con una autoestima bajo
y mientras no estarían equivocados
tampoco estarían en lo correcto
porque normalmente estas personas
tienden a mostrarse normal
ante la gente
no hay un solo prototipo de una mujer
que es propensa
o que está sufriendo de violencia
doméstica
puede ser la persona que ahorita tienes
a tu lado
así que en vez de enfocarnos en las
características de una persona que está
sufriendo violencia
vamos a mejor preguntarnos por qué te
quedan
todo el mundo tiene un montón de
prejuicios y mitos acerca de la
violencia doméstica
qué mujer más tonta
porque se quedó
ella se merece que la lástima porque
ella no le pone un fin
es que a la mujer le encanta que la
traten mal y la mía mi favorita es es
que las mujeres son masoquistas
a esta joven de la que les contaba
pasó o transcurrió un año con agresiones
similares a las que le describí
para agarrar sus maletas
sus hijos e irse de una vez por todas
un año
entonces porque se queda en las mujeres
porque aguantamos tanto
y decidimos a jugar acá si está feliz
con nuestros agresores
te les quiero contar la historia del
sapo
las personas que saben de los campos
saben dos cosas
y les gusta la temperatura helada
y tiene cuatro patas para saltar del
lugar en lugar donde se agarramos un
sapo y lo metemos en una olla con agua
lo ponemos encima de la estufa y le
subimos la temperatura al low
qué va a pasar con el saco
y ahí se va a quedar el sapo se acomoda
subamos la temperatura a medio que cree
usted que va a pasar con el sapo
ya lo vamos a empezar a ver un poco más
incómodo que va a estar moviendo va a
empezar a hacer sonidos
pero ahí se queda
ahora qué pasa si le subimos a la
temperatura a high
el sapo 9 quemada
y uno dice pero sapo que poco
porque te quedaste dentro de la olla
teniendo cuatro patas para saltar fuera
de ella decíamos no te gusta la
temperatura caliente
es lo que pasa el sapo se acomodó o se
acopló a sus circunstancias lo mismo
pasa con nosotros los humanos
en 1977
se utiliza el término el síndrome de la
mujer violentada por primera vez y viene
a cambiar la perspectiva de género
completamente
estas son características los síntomas
que las mujeres desarrollan
o sea una impotencia aprendida a causa
de haber sido
participe de tanto ciclo de violencia de
haber sufrido tanto ciclo de violencia
no sé qué es lo que pasa la mujer se da
por vencida la mujer
y logra identificarse con su agresor
y hasta cierto punto
entiende o piensa que se merece estos
agresiones
y empieza a su agresor que justifica los
tratos
y lo peor del caso es que esto se vive
en silencio
muchas de las personas no hablan
entonces esto hace que el problema sea
difícil de visualizarlo incluso para sus
seres queridos
y
y lo más lo más difícil de solucionar de
todo esto
a veces y las víctimas saben que son
víctimas de violencia
y ustedes alguna vez se han preguntado
si han sufrido de violencia doméstica
ya sea física verbal emocional o
psicológica
el 911 recibe aproximadamente entre
3.800 y 4.000 denuncias diarias de abuso
doméstico
lastimosamente el número inicial baja a
900 denuncias cuando la mujer ve a su
agresor ya detenido
así que yo les invito el día de hoy a
que denuncien y esto incluye a los
hombres también se aproxima que un 5 por
ciento de las denuncias son hechas por
hombres
es hora de decir
así que rompamos el silencio
denunciemos
y yo lo hice y a mí me salvó la vida
porque esa historia que yo le conté al
comienzo en la mía
así que siempre levanta la mano
levantas el teléfono
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]